[Music]
hi I'm in a dead zone once again but now
I'm with Terrence Ryan who's one of my
favorite co-workers I'm not gonna lie
about that but so this demo in
particular it's a digital postcard is
that right yeah it's kind of the idea it
is you take a selfie or a picture and we
will bounce it around our network our
private network all around the world and
print it out for you so the pictures
that you get over here our pictures that
have traveled around the world digitally
each data center each data center we
have a stamp for it and it doesn't stamp
it until it's in that data center now
when you talk about a private network
you mean the actual physical cables and
data centers that Google built around
the world right exactly the same data
centers and same infrastructure that
powers search and Mail also under the
covers it's available to Google cloud
customers as their private networks so
whenever you talk between one machine
and another machine on Google cloud
that's always traveling on our network
it never leaves the network and so you
get much better performance in terms of
being able to communicate and security
because it's not leaving it's not on the
public Internet oh my gosh this is
actually where my favorite facts about
Google cloud it's a fun fact which is we
built an infrastructure to power our
search and then we started opening that
up to other people so that you don't
have to reinvent the wheel but it's
really important that we make it easy to
use was this pretty easy to set up
absolutely like one of the great things
about Google clouds default networking
in our projects is if all the machines
are in the same project all the VMS the
vm Tsar ordered powering and relaying
and the stamping here if they're all in
the same project then they are
automatically wired to talk to one
another without the developer having to
do any work to make that happen
and so what that allows you to do is
kind of get started without you know
having to set up like VPNs
cease to get all that working all of
that is done for you all the routing is
done for you and if you want this is an
open source project so you can actually
pull down and see how we set it up and
see that like it really is that super
simple and I like that it makes it
accessible to someone who might not have
that networking experience or background
but as long as they can understand the
theory they can actually get going yep
exactly this is so exciting I love this
demo I am so happy to take home my
photos and more importantly the fact
that it is open source means that anyone
at home can play along even if you don't
get to have your own cute photo to take
home and I hope you'll have a great time
and thanks for joining me in the dead
zone
[Music]